day four of our school matters series
this week we examine what some are
calling a growing national crisis the
shortage of school nurses only three out
of five schools across the country have
full-time school nurses this often
forces school administrators with no
medical training to step in and provide
some level of care
Hilary Lane is here with the potential
dangers to students when no nurse is
available Hillary good morning John good
morning the role of the school nurse is
more critical than ever with a quarter
of all young children suffering some
kind of chronic illness like asthma and
diabetes over the past several years
multiple children have died after facing
medical emergencies in their schools
when no nurse was on duty
parents and nerds advocates now want to
see that changed did the school district
fail your child lady Pelham always they
weren't here to help you last October
Roisin Presley's nine-year-old son
Hassan collapsed in the school cafeteria
he was rushed to the hospital where he
was later pronounced dead of heart
failure what went through your mind and
in those last moments there was no
school nurse on duty that day according
to a Philadelphia school district
official staff certified in CPR tried to
revive Hassan who'd been born with a
heart defect it's unknown how to school
nurse been there that day if they would
have been able to save Rasheen son do
you think things would have been
different if there was a school nurse
there that day I think so that would
know Kareem Presley is the boy's uncle
it's the hardest just gotta be tough
there because he by here did Miss Millie
talk to you before there are no federal
laws regulating school nurse staffing
but the American Academy of Pediatrics
recommends at least one registered nurse
in every school a standard many
districts are failing to me that is a
crisis
Donna Mazique the executive director of
the National Association of school
nurses says 40% of schools across the
country don't have a full-time nurse and
25% don't have a nurse at all is that
acceptable it's not acceptable students
deserve what they need in order to be in
school and ready to learn ma Zeke blames
shrinking budgets for the shortfall
which she says increases the burden on
existing nurses and puts kids at risk if
you have a workload that doesn't enable
you to care for the students in the way
they need it's like drinking water from
a fire hose so now time for school
number two yes my elementary school dean
Igor B crease is a school nurse in
Howard County Maryland who covers two
schools a day I'm often stressed because
I have to figure out the safest way to
balance it she has health assistants at
each school who call her with questions
when she's not in the building
if I'm busy with an emergency at my
other school I'm not available right
away so it might delay there at their
care song as a school nurse do you feel
like you're stretched too thin I think
so I would love to be able to be in one
place so that I could provide the care
that the kids need I
my nose in Cincinnati Ohio where nurses
were also sometimes covering more than
one school they're tackling the problem
through a partnership with Cincinnati
Children's Hospital we now are able to
provide routine primary care services
for all of the students in the building
as well as any child in the community
they've opened house centers in schools
to close the gap so students get
services here no different than they do
in a pediatricians office in the wake of
his son's death Roisin Presley says
schools must find a way to provide care
for all students they're being I know
nurses at the school you might as well
miles along teachers teaching kids at
home that's just common sense the
Philadelphia School District is working
with a local hospital to determine if
and what kind of additional health
support is needed in the schools and
next month a bill will be reintroduced
in Washington called the nurse Act it
would provide grants for schools to hire
nurses good our priorities need to
change this is an issue heart goes out
to the fuzzies listen they said listen
we don't know if the nurse would have
made a difference but at least you would
have known everything would have been
done to help them try thank you that's
what they say a school nurse just should
have been that exactly we should say for
our school matter series CBS this
morning partnered with USA Today to
feature extended stories and
investigations on education so go to
usatoday.com for a new article published
this morning on the increasing demands
for school nurses as students mental and
physical health problems increase we
will be right back